good morning
is that all you have to say for yourself
you haven't returned any of my calls
this week it's all i can do to not
imagine you lying dead in a ditch
somewhere right back at you mom
what did you want to talk about too late
i'm not speaking to you
all right would you like to know why
no i trust your judgment
because when your brother's marriage
ended yes i know alan blah blah blah
and he chose to move in here your
coldness towards your mother became more
than just the behavior of an ungrateful
son it's now an obstacle to my spending
quality time with my beloved grandchild
are you coming to disney now with us
grandma oh darling grandma doesn't do
anaheim well uh you better hit the road
try to beat the traffic thanks for
dropping by mom come on let's go jake uh
race you to the car come on charlie
bye wait for me i'm going
so
where's your brother why what'd he get
nothing i just want to make sure he
knows why
he's in his room he's been sulking all
weekend
sulking
about what well it's the silliest thing
i i just happen to mention that in the
unlikely event that judith should die
and i should die that custody of jake
would go to
custody of jake would go to who uh
actually it would be whom
alan
who gets jake now see that's
grammatically correct
alan
jerry and faye
jerry and faye who
your
sister's son and his wife
them
you would bypass your own mother in
favor of two potato farmers on long
island
they're agriculture professors in rhode
island
really
who am i thinking of who lives on long
island
i have no idea
well regardless i am deeply insulted oh
come on mom this is only if judith and i
both die and we're not dying at least
not before you
oh now you're wishing me death no no mom
no
give me back my picture
no better you should look at it and feel
shame
so what's up
okay well you know how the other night
at dinner we were talking about the
whole silly putty deal mm-hmm did that
venison disagree with you
yeah that's not what i came here to talk
about
got a good mind to sue that restaurant
yeah anyway
about the silly putty what about it
alan didn't steal it
i did
i
put it in his pocket
you framed your baby brother
[Laughter]
how could you i know i know it was a
rotten thing to do rotten
it's unspeakable
do you have any idea what you put me
through
you
first the embarrassment of people
thinking that i'd spawned a petty thief
then all the trouble i went to trying to
figure out clever ways to hide my
jewelry from his sticky little finger
okay mom that's really not not to
mention the hundreds of hours spent
driving him to therapy with that creepy
dr demarist while i could have been
i don't know
doing something fun
okay yeah it was a real imposition on
you and as it turns out it had kind of a
negative impact on alan too
alan
oh yes of course
you know
there was no insurance for kleptomania
therapy in those days it was all out of
pocket
yeah
but about alan
i was hoping you might have some insight
as to how i could get him to forgive me
why ask me
you know i'm starting to wonder that
myself
i guess it's because he still loves you
despite all the
lousy stuff you did to him
i beg your pardon
i was a wonderful mother
and if alan thinks otherwise it's only
because that wall-eyed dr demaris put
ideas into his head
well that was money well spent
okay then
i didn't need a reason to drink tonight
but it's nice to know i've got one
hey charlie wait
what have you forgotten why you came
here you want forgiveness right
yes
well i forgive you
but next time call first
mom thank god you're here oh i don't
need your sarcasm charlie
no i mean it i need you alan needs you
what's going on
alan tell mom your plans for the weekend
no why embarrassed no ashamed no
scared yes
sweetheart i'm your mother you can tell
me anything
okay um
i met a wonderful woman in the
supermarket a few days ago and
we're getting married
i see
god sake if you're that horny find a
nice call girl put her on retainer
this is not about sex please what else
could it be it could be love
yeah sure
who is this woman what does she do
she does alan
okay okay that that is how it started
but but in the last day and a half it
has blossomed into so much more oh
my randy little nincompoo
listen if i had gotten married after
every weekend of hot sweaty debauchery
with a virtual stranger you'd have
well
many more stepfathers than you already
have
she knows what she's talking about alan
mom's been on more hotel pillows than a
chocolate mint
[Applause]
don't help me charlie
now now this is sweetheart sweetheart no
offense but since you're dirt poor
and living with your brother one must
ask what kind of woman would agree to
marry you unless she's a little slow or
looking for a green card
listen to your mommy allen
no
no i am going to listen to my heart and
for your information she hasn't agreed
to marry me in fact i haven't even asked
her yet but you're planning to yes
i'm not going to hit you darling
charlie
ah
okay look i will thank you both to let
me live my own life i love nancy and
nancy loves me and if this is a mistake
then it will be my mistake
hello
nancy you uh you missed me i miss you
um listen there's something i want to
ask you but i want to do it in person
oh oh okay okay i understand yeah sure
sure bye
um her husband came back a day early
okay my mistake right cynthia's in the
ground my face is on i look stunning in
black let's go to dinner
just follow my lead
um
mom
yes dad
alan thinks you're a crazy shebac no no
morning your funeral either
we're telling you this because we love
you
i see
look mom
you have to realize that you're not that
different from cynthia
i most certainly am oh come on mom you
you speak ill of everyone even your
closest friends you you manipulate
people you're an unbelievable narcissist
you're self-obsessed that's a bit
redundant isn't it
you find fault with everything
and frankly i don't know anyone who
enjoys spending time with you let alone
would cry at your funeral
that's one point of view
charlie
i notice you haven't said anything
actually
crazy she bat was mine
again mom we're only telling you this
because we care about you right charlie
we care about you
and and it's not too late for you to
change and become the kind of person
that people would dearly miss
when you're dead
you've given me a lot to think about yes
and and while you're thinking remember
the spirit in which it was intended
oh i won't forget that
good good listen um i think i'm going to
beg off dinner tonight good good oh
where is my new assistant
oh you didn't
morning all right darling put this on oh
snazzy do i get to keep it uh no but if
this works out i'll sell it to your
cause
you're going to work for mom what else
am i supposed to do i don't know some
job that lets you keep your self-respect
like you know man [ __ ]
dog dewormer
outhouse inspector
good morning charlie hey mom how are you
laxative tester horse inseminator
i'm gonna work weekends with mom selling
real estate and she's gonna give me a
piece of the action no
i said having an assistant would give me
a little piece so i could get some
action
or whatever it's a start
let's go no dear
i say let's go
oh oh okay let's go
oh stop
take my bag
now let's go
this is gonna be fun
you're very welcome
thanks for coming
oh the rat bastards live right across
the street
you probably just came for the free
cookies
um mom i have to go to the bathroom
number one or number two
what difference does it make
alan i'm trying to sell a house here
warm cookie smell good hot poop smell
bad
i'll wait you're damn right yo
so the people who own this live mostly
in new york oh they have homes all over
the place probably only remember they
have this one hardly seems fair well
fair go live in like the bullets
honey
how's that work exactly do you have to
be jewish
oh ah welcome welcome uh please sign in
uh there's juice and cookies in the
kitchen
[Applause]
so this is it we're just going to sit
here watching television until dinner
time
i'm open to do until bedtime
we can't talk
what would you like to talk about don't
encourage her alan well what comes
immediately to mine is the futility of
love the disappointment of family and
the inevitability of death i'd be right
with you if inevitable meant now
i'm sorry but i cannot go along with you
two gloomy gusses i look at life and i
see the cup is half full
but the cup belongs to your brother and
what it's half full of is tears
good one mom
you're no longer talk
he at least aspires to normalcy
tries to have meaningful relationships
with women you go out with a girl and
break up with her before her huh can
develop a five o'clock shadow
well uh in his defense mom you're
usually paying by the hour
very smart alan bite the syphilitic hand
that feeds you
well if neither of you is going to
refill my drink i'll do it myself
help yourself mom
i keep the vodka in a bleach bottle
men men
[Music]
man